[Musique]
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté pas une
pas deux trois motions uneanimes contre
ces cibles tous les élus du Québec sont
contre le gouvernement s'engageait de ne
pas aussi l'immigration jusqu'à 100
millions de citoyens en 2005 le Canada
devrait-il compter 100 millions
d'habitants d'ici 2100 cette suggestion
du groupe de réflexion l'initiative du
siècle a soulevé la controverse la
semaine dernière à Québec qui craint
l'impact de pareil croissant sur son
poids démographique un débat qui a aussi
mis en relief les quarts entre les
ambitieux cibles d'immigration d'Ottawa
elle est limite que s'imposent François
le groupe les deux visions sont-elles
conciliables que pensent Ottawa de la
proposition de l'initiative du siècle
j'en ai discuté avec le ministre fédéral
de l'immigration
bonjour merci d'être avec nous merci
c'est un plaisir d'être ici avec vous
aussi monsieur freezer on a beaucoup
beaucoup parlé d'immigration cette
semaine commençons par
l'initiative du siècle
quel est le lien entre votre
gouvernement et les gens de l'initiative
du siècle permettez-moi d'être très
clair les initiatives du cirque n'est
pas la politique pour le gouvernement
falloir pas pour notre élément c'est une
organisation en dépendante c'est une
partie prénom mais il y a plus de 3000
personnes organisations qui participent
dans le processus pour un conseil de
l'oeil les perspectives les communautés
pour mettre les niveaux d'immigration
mais les cibles pour 2025 de 500 mg
c'est pas mal ce que propose les gens de
l'initiative du siècle
coïncidence j'ai y arriver à la cible
appropriée pour les Canada alors parce
que il a besoin
à augmenter le nombre de travailleurs
avec la compétence essentielles pour
faire croire sur l'économie c'est
essentiel aussi pour accueillir des
personnes et des jeunes familles parce
que nous avons un défi plus grande avec
la démographie du Canada mais c'est
essentiel aussi pour moi des conseils
des perspectives à des autres
organisations des organisations qui a
fait la suggestions pour accueillir des
nouveaux arrivants francophones les
organisations qui soutenir des personnes
qui est plus vivant dans la table en mai
ce n'est pas un vrai que l'unicité du
siècle a créé la politique polyguments
c'est incroyable et ce n'est pas vrai
est-ce qu'on a les infrastructures pour
les accueillir ces gens-là c'est souvent
la critique des villes ou des provinces
de dire oui on a quand même des gens
mais ça veut dire des maisons des
logements des places en garderie les
soins de santé vous dites quoi à ceux
qui disent on va peut-être un peu trop
vite mais oui c'est important pour
construire des autres facteurs le
logement à leçon de santé des autres
services publics mais quand nous avons
une plante pour aprio de personnes à
nucléaire aussi pour
essentiel pour créer des opportunités et
pour des personnes qui non maman
arrivaient à Toronto Montréal
des communautés petites mais c'est pas
facile les gens ils savent pas si
facilement que ça des grands centres les
gens quand ils arrivent oui vous voulez
les envoyer dans de plus petites
communautés mais les gens débarquent au
Canada puissent à Montréal à Toronto
avant couvert mais essaye très
intéressant vu que commencer les cités
au Canada qui expérimentent le plus
rapide croissance maintenant
ajouter le nombre d'espace pour le
Provence de choisir les personnes avec
les stratégies pour encourager des
personnes
aussi de comprendre les personnes qui
arrivent au Canada à labilité pour
améliorer la situation avec avec
logement à cette tournée c'est possible
pour moi pour la première fois de
conduire un processus pour choisir des
personnes qui a l'habilité pour
construire des logements les personnes
qui a l'habilité travail dans la chambre
de santé qu'est-ce que vous pensez le
Québec des traits vocales la semaine
dernière sur la capacité de la province
à accueillir des immigrants et on trouve
aussi les gouvernement québécois trouve
au cible trop ambitieuse c'est trop
rapide comprenez vous leurs inquiétudes
je comprends le réseau pour l'inquiéter
les pressions sur la communauté
francophone et ici le Bertrand c'est
irréal mais c'est très important de
comprendre l'euro pour le gouvernement
falal et l'euro pour le gouvernement du
Québec nous avons avec Québec et la
cause a établir les responsabilités pour
le Québec et pour mettre les niveaux des
migration et
choisi chaque personne qui arrivait dans
les voies économiques nous envoyons
projeter 700 millions de dollars pour
relation francisation mais il a contrôle
et le pouvoir pour choisir les personnes
à rester avec la première mais le Québec
dit si on essaie de les intégrer
convenablement et qu'on le fait plus
lentement et que vous maintenez vos cils
à 500 000 par année le poids du Québec
diminue dans le reste du Canada puis
mathématiquement ils ont raison vous
dites quoi ça mais je comprends les
parents pour la communauté et c'est une
priorité pour moi dans les enjeux congés
juridictions juste pour exemple l'année
dernière et le plus grand nombre de
nouveaux arrivants en général mais
l'année dernière aussi et le nombre avec
le plus grand
pourcentage de nouveaux arrivants
francophones qui arrivaient au Canada au
Québec les décisions pour le nombre de
personnes et les nombres de personnes
avec les compétences linguistiques car
il y a au Québec c'est une décision pour
Québec donc c'est la faute du Québec le
Québec est responsable de le Québec père
de son poids démographique dans le
Canada c'est un choix que Québec fait
c'est ce que vous dites et je comprends
les défis assez essentiel pour moi de
protéger les problèmes graphiques de
francophones au Canada mais c'est plus
important de protéger la vérité pour la
communication
et de vivre leur vie en français pour
utiliser l'école en français les
galeries en français c'est très
important quand j'ai des réunions avec
les communautés francophones les trois
dermographiques et important mais les
décisions pour le nombre de nouveaux
arrivants au Québec et pour le ministre
du Québec
vous êtes à la tête d'un ministère qui a
des centaines de milliers de dossiers en
attente de traitement ça va ça va mal
tout est lent tout est en retard on
dirait que ça va jamais bien au
ministère de l'Immigration pourquoi j'ai
bonnet maintenant après beaucoup
d'efforts après des réseaux sociaux plus
des personnes qui travaillent dans ma
monastère pour traiter des cartes avec
des nouveaux technologies et avec des
changements de les politiques et
administratives ne réduisons à les temps
pour traiter les cases juste pour
exemple les dans les systèmes fédéral
pour les 15 polaires
c'est le même trompe maintenant après le
pandémie pour les classes économiques
dont les voies ferrées six mois c'est le
même temps aujourd'hui et pour avoir le
pandémie pour les permis de travail les
permis d'études c'est très proche comme
soit ton jour maintenant donc ça va bien
ça va bien
mais non c'est essentiel pour réétablir
les attentes pour traiter les cases qui
existent avant la pandémie mais la
prochaine étape et pour déterminer si le
Standard est propriété pour le
compétitions avec des autres
juridictions ainsi des personnes qui
considèrent le Canada ou United France
pour pour voyager et il y a
à côté le fameux pour chercher des
opportunités le temps pour traiter les
cas ensuite une facture importante ce
n'est pas le seul facteur mais c'est
important merci beaucoup c'est un
plaisir merci pour la continuité